when is the checkout population es rahsing
first and second is because it was the
one step
at the moment the ports energy
consumption of about 6000 tiger woods in
future will increase separates the 1000
guests unit gigawatt peak ossi to remember
away when nuclear power is planned
against
the figures from nuclear 100 percent with
16,000 nuclear power plan like montevideo
co2
and web services internet for two years we
have to install shifting 1000 megawatts
on the uk cities of you have to build
everyday nuclear power plan from fertiva
as well as
be it on the program i  have is really
so extra a rehabilitation clinic news
solutions
for the way i can say desertec wants to
use natural nokia fusion but fishing
projector axxis for reggae is but tell
me something safety distance of 150 images
kilometers long is highly active and
can cloister a realistic  hefte
picture us dollar table with happy energy
and mac user sees
the energy problem is and
technology wit simple and safe and
renewables last forever
more immediately than ever before monte user of the us giant is
simply because the most of the energy
for just use  karen technology you had
about when the dance solar energy
days of the world
so bit berti
potential of solar energy and the desert
is immense
danilo wyss simple technology and
technology baby believe i have to do it
in huge number otherwise you will
try
a problem on that  there will be the
decisive
match in the
specifications power and night with
electricity night and simple way to do
it used in this concentrating solar
power stations is just the way you
don't stop the electricity it's up to us
light that can be very simple
now then  built into the big think thanks
to liquid giulietta pure the story to
the second hand calls for the crisis
and if it is after unique users location
in
discos electric
car here we bring electric deep
from will the so people power days at
sea life center jsc cable im  detail
voltage and unity sieggarant
normal but electro sitting at work is
se automatic guarantor des as i can t stop
losses giant one reason speaker the
previews electrosmog in the broadcast
electromagnetics way you know center
yassin idbihi don't have much anymore
and the power los best  knows
presenter per 1000 kilometers
the station sixx aspect on desertec
foundation talk about either the
geopolitics respect here in european
special situations
but not the place and africa like no
matter rice on population like
butter is david villa and fast future
climate change in the region people
living and poverty and the good food and
water and des wants to be on the podium spot
problems in africa sing europe and
therefore we believe that for europe what
costs it's important to have been cheering
changed ebadis even more important to
secure mail box
deposit
energy producers water at the saline
from africa our house to new
yorks there will be europe it in africa
it ends peacekeeping incentives because
it's table effects